yeah thank you for the introduction lion
and thanks to all the organizers for
the invitation to speak here um so
let me remind you of what i'm going to
prove so a is going to be the adjacency
matrix of an error shiny graph
where the edge probabilities are d over
n and you should think of d
as being a constant and we're going to
use a bar to denote
the centered adjacency matrix
and our goal is going to be to show that
if x is
any positive semi-definite matrix with
once on the diagonals
then with high probability uh the value
of the
elk non-backtracking part of the
centered adjacency matrix
um it starts out with x is at most the
square root
d to the l quantity uh so okay strictly
speaking
we're going to show it's at most one
plus epsilon to the l squared d to the l
for large enough constant l where l
depends on epsilon
but from now on i'm just going to use
less than approximately equal to two
to hide this one plus epsilon to the n
um hey can i ask i'm sorry to jump in so
early in your talk but this is actually
a question sort of from the combination
of the two talks
so this sdp doesn't have
any new constraints on x it's the what's
different from the kind of good
old-fashioned stp is that you're taking
the inner product with
this backtracking length l power instead
of
the adjacency matrix so is this
forgive me but is this somehow dual to
the idea of taking a more complicated
stp with more
constraints that that jess was talking
about i guess they're
right this is a simple stp with a
different
inner product thing as opposed to an stp
with
more constraints am i missing something
um obvious here yeah i guess i'm not
really sure what you mean by duel
i think i think that uh yeah because i
had the same confusion as chris
but all of these are constraints right
yeah all these are beneficial this
inequality a l dot x
less than square root of n d to the l
for each l
right right so now that i can jump and i
i think i could have set this up better
in mind
the point is that this little results
are very large results as it turns out
that
that's enough to prove is just showing
that some particular constraint is
violated
uh in in the stp with lots of
constraints that i mentioned in the
prior talk
right right so actually for the planet
model uh if you're above the ks
threshold then
this a dot l dot x where x is a planted
solution is going to be
way larger than square root of d to the
l and here we are showing that the null
model it cannot exceed square root of d
to the l
uh and hence the null model can never
hope to satisfy this particular
constraint
um okay yeah so um
i guess you should state that the stp is
just check the feasibility of all of
these constraints
for a child yeah that's that's exactly
right
and also uh chime in prasad okay sorry
prasad ragavandra says as a comment at
degree 2 local statistics reduces to
non-backtracking locks
since the only local statistics with two
labeled vertices are non-backtracking
walks
right okay yeah so i guess we
we wanted to prove this bound on the scp
value of square d to the l
uh and before i move on i just want to
point out that several of these ideas
um actually do come from are inspired by
previous papers uh
namely once by burden of large messories
and also some joint work with um ron
o'donnell and
pedro pardesh um but the main technical
challenge here
is somehow getting the statement to work
for
l being a large constant whereas these
previous works can only
get such a statement to work for l being
something like
log log squared n
and as a first attempt you could make
the observation
that actually the elf non-backlashing
power um
that the object on the elf
non-backdragon part is actually an upper
band on
the stp value and one could
hope to prove the bound that we want by
banning the operator arm um
but actually can't do this directly
fails
and it actually fails for a fairly
simple reason
because with high probability an
additional graph is actually going to
have
vertices of degree roughly log n
which automatically gives the matrix
a super constant eigenvalue
but actually this band that we want to
show square d to the l
is a constant oh but actually the reason
for which this fails
also gives this a simple fix
so what we can notice is that a typical
vertex has degree d or more generally
if you look in the distance t
neighborhood of typical vertex
you're going to see roughly d to the
power t neighbors
and there's only going to be like a very
small fraction
of um vertices
whose balls exceed this d to the t
number
by a lot
uh and what we're going to do is we're
going to delete
the small number of vertices from the
graph uh
by the way notice that this is just
something for the analysis
so let let me define m to be the elf
non-backtracking power
of the adjacency matrix of
the graph where um a certain bad version
is mutilated
but bad vertices are the ones which
participate in short cycles and also the
ones that have
large distance free neighborhoods uh
and actually since we have this
particular constraint on the scp
that the diagonal entries are all equal
to one
um we can actually show that
deletion of vertices does not really
influence the stp value by much
and it turns out this new matrix
m is indeed spectrally bounded
by square root d to the l
so now um we're going to jump into the
proof
of bounding the operating off m but i'm
going to pause for a second to save
their questions
well since you ask so deleting vertices
on short cycles feels a little bit like
up to some point using
self-avoiding random walks rather than
just non-battering or
non-backtracking or if you like
non-backtracking with a bit more memory
right like you may not visit any of the
past
uh three or four or five places you've
been
so right i'm just wondering if there's
anything to be gained by
that kind of power of the adjacency
matrix
since non-backtracking sort of has
memory one
yeah so uh i guess i'm actually still
not sure of how to make the proof go
through
if we use self-avoiding walks for
reasons that that i will i will address
actually on the next slide
um right so our approach for bounding
the opinion of m
is actually to start by bounding its
skate moment by some number c
and once we have a bound on the kth
moment of c
um if k is like a large enough number
then we actually have a bound on the
operator norm that holds with high
probability
of c to the power one over k
uh and the way we're going to try to
bound the kth moment
of m of of the operating of m
is to notice that when we choose k to be
an even number
the op amp of m is actually bounded by
the trace of the kth power of m
um and
actually the hope is that the expected
a trace of the case part is at most
um square root d to the l whole thing to
the power k
so so is is what we want so so we can
get the
desired operator non-bound on m and
um chris i'll get you a question very
soon
so um our first natural goal is actually
to
try and understand what the
trace of the case bar of m actually is
and if you do a little bit of
combinatorics um
you will see that the trace of m to the
k
is like a sum over a huge variety of
walks
and in the summer huge variety of walks
the summon is actually an appropriate
weight of a certain walk and now let's
understand
what uh this huge collection of boxes
so ashley recall that m was the
l non-backtracking power of
um of a certain centered adjacency
matrix
so trace of m to the case actually
counting
i was actually summing over closed box
which have length k times l and
these closed box have a very special
structure
in particular they're composed of k
non-backtracking segments
each of which have length exactly equal
to l
so okay now let me quickly address
chris's question
so if we instead use self-awarding works
instead of non-backtracking works
uh then we'd be looking for a walks
where there's
case self-avoiding segments of length
and each
but as you pass from one self-warning
segment to another
you could still encounter short cycles
and this could cause
problems in our analysis
so okay i'm gonna momentarily pause here
too to see if
um people have any more questions
okay so now let me keep going
um so this particular trace of m to the
k quantity
it's like this crazy sum over all walks
and looks
super daunting um so actually
fortunately i'm not gonna make any of
you
actually think about this um let me just
say that there's
a lot of song and dance that one needs
to go through before
you get to get from this point to
something interesting so i'm going to
perform a sleight of hand
and fast forward to where the next
interesting thing happens um and
here by waving my hands a little bit i'm
going to say that this face of amp to
the k which is like a sum of a vox
weight of w
is dominated by um
a very small number of
walks with very nice structure in
particular it's dominated by walks
which are even that is every edge is
walked on an
even number of times and also these
blocks have the property that
they have almost no cycles
they're very close to tree and all the
cycles on them are also
very long and
the first interesting combinatorial
question
in in trying to account for these walks
is to count walks on a tree
so let let me set up
a clean combinatorial question so you
have a dre tree
it's rooted at this vertex which has
been labeled as v
and we want to count the total number of
closed box
that um start at v and retrieve these
closed box need to have length k out
and they need to have special structure
that they're composed of k
length l non-backtracking segments
and recall that we'd be happy if
the bound we could get on the number of
such blocks
is a square root of d to the l
and the way we are going to bound the
number of closed box is
one encoding argument so if you give me
any walk
on on the street and if i can
compress the description of this walk to
log of some number c bits
then i've actually bounded the total
number of blocks by c
so in particular um i'll have to give
you an encoding
of a closed box of the special structure
in the tree using kl over 2 times log d
bits now uh the first
observation that that goes into
uh this particular encoding is that
uh okay so first let me define what an
up step is and what a down step is
so notice that every step in this walk
either moves away from the root or moves
closer to the root
so if a step moves closer to the root
you can think of it as climbing the tree
and we call it an up step
and if it moves away from the root we
can think of it as descending that
down the tree and we can call that a
down step
uh and because you have to start it we
and end it feed the number of
offsets is actually equal to the number
of down steps in particular half the
steps are up and half the steps are down
now here's the second observation and
this is where we're going to use like
the special structure of the walk of
being composed of
k non backtracking segments which each
have length l
so in one of these length l
non-backtracking segments
uh i claim the structure as always i
move s
steps up and l minus s steps down
where s is possibly zero
and the reason uh for
this kind of structure is if i take a
down step
the only moves i can make in
non-backtracking fashion
are also damp steps
so this this actually really constrains
what a
segment can look like and this is going
to
inform the following way to actually
encode a walk you give me a walk w
and then what i'm going to do is in each
segment i'm going to see
what this number s is like how many up
steps are there
it's going to be a number between 0 and
l so i'm going to use
log l bits to write down how many up
steps are taken per segment
so for example maybe this per the
encoding just looks like zero up
two up three up five up um and so on
and um
and notice that this takes log l bits
per segment so that accounts for k times
log l bits
so um another thing i want to point out
is if i tell you that you're taking an
upstep or if you know that you're taking
an outstep
i don't need to tell you where you're
going because
every vertex has a unique parent
but if you're taking a down step i do
need value where you're going in
in particular i need to tell you which
of your d children you're going to
so um encoding each damp step takes
log d bits and since half the steps
of the kl steps are down
this accounts for log d times scale over
two
and actually this log d times scale over
2 is like the number of bits you wanted
but we have like a bit of bonus
okay but the surplus number of bits um
ends up being
something pretty insignificant that
you're paying only log l over l
per up step and that's the source of
your savings
so this establishes how one counts
works in a dre tree
so now i'm going to move on to an
overview of
how one actually counts blocks that have
um some small number of cycles in them
but
before that i'm again going to pause for
a second to see if there are any
questions
okay so um let me keep going
so we actually now care about
understanding walks on shapes that may
contain some cycles
so in particular you could have some
graph that looks like
the one on the left and there's some
vertex v and we want to count
v to be closed box which satisfy the
same set of conditions that
we discussed earlier um
but this is no longer free
so actually the strategy at this point
and i would say this is like roughly
where new ideas start coming in and
we depart from past work is uh to
identify a spanning tree as well as a
set of excess edges namely the others
which are
not in spanning tree and now once we
have a decomposition of the shape
into a spanning tree plus excess edges
we note that any walk
breaks down into an
alternating um fashion where
there's there's a stretch of the walk
that's on the tree followed by a stretch
that's on the excess edges
followed by a stretch on the tree and so
on
and uh now the way we're going to encode
such a walk
is um by actually encoding
the three segments in an almost
identical way
to what was described earlier so note
that
actually the three segments are no
longer close box because
really they go from one end point of an
excess edge to another endpoint
of an excess edge and these two end
points need not be the same vertex
um but i guess if so first say that
an almost identical idea works for
encoding these these segments of the
tree walk
and actually the way we're going to
encode um excess steps is also
rather naive for each excess step that
appears we're simply going to
list we're just going to make this big
list of excess address
in the order in which they appeared in
the walk
so i i just like wrote an example
encoding
at the bottom but actually if
the number of steps on exercise is
too big we go down to trouble because
this this list of excess steps could
could be really large
so we can't just choose any spanning
tree
we need to be clever about which
spanning tree
we choose and i guess a rather
um natural choice of which spanning tree
to use
would be you take the shape and then you
weigh every edge
by the number of times
it appears in the walk and
choose the maximum spanning tree
according to
these at weights so
this this choice definitely minimizes
the
um the number of excess steps
that one takes it it minimizes the list
of the excess step encoding
however it's still not actually clear
that
the list you get is short enough in
length
and um yeah i won't have time to
to get into how one actually proves that
this list of exercises
is very small but um
it's actually a part of the proofs that
i really like and it it involves like
some nice tools from combinatorics such
as the
more bound for irregular brass as well
as
properties of a linear programming
relaxation of
um finding massive spanning tree
and this actually ends the
technical part of my talk and now
i'm just gonna discuss three future
directions
and then we'll have time for questions
so um the most natural next question is
the following
this local statistics thing um gives us
an algorithm for
the distinguishing problem it's natural
as whether the search problem
could be solved uh so okay let me be a
bit more specific when i say search
problem
you want to so so the basic version of
search problems you want to recover
say in the two communications you want
to cover the two communities
um better than random guessing word
but actually there's a more
nuanced question here which is um for
a given two community block model with
certain settings parameters there is an
optimal
um possible recovery that you can
perform information theoretically
and there's a paper of mosul nemonian
sly which does this but not right down
to the case threshold they do it at like
some factor maybe 10 uh above the case
threshold
so one question is whether rounding the
local statistics stp
um could achieve could
could solve this problem right down to
the case threshold
and yeah there's a problem that probably
needs like
new ideas and could be very interesting
uh another direction is well we
illustrated how to apply this um
scp to a certain hypothesis to
the hypothesis has some question of
community detection but one could ask
whether it could be applied to other
natural questions such as finding planet
spikes and wiggle matrices or
planet solutions in random constraint
satisfaction problems
um and here's another direction that
that's um that would be to try to apply
these ideas
beyond the realm of bayesian inference
in particular let's say you want to
determine moments of
gibbs distributions for your favorite
problem
like let's say yeah let's say you had a
d regular graph and you wanted to know
what
the moments of the uniform distribution
on 2d call rings
were and there are algorithms for
sampling from gates distributions in
some cases using
global dynamics or more generally some
form of markovian monte carlo
but the question is can the local
statistics std be used to give
deterministic algorithms in these
settings
and i think with that i'm done
uh okay let's uh thank jess and sit down
together
see if i can pipe in
applause
i should have faded that out uh okay
great so uh now i guess uh jess and
siddhanth can potentially even team up
on answers to questions that you may all
have
for which we still have plenty of time
i just want to check with chris whether
i answered his question about
self-avoiding walks
uh my question was a little vague so yes
you did
i was just trying to connect it with i
guess masulia's
positive result from some years ago
about using
uh the matrix that counted self-avoiding
walks up to a certain length
i wonder if one of the things you've
done is find a simpler proof of that
somehow sort of kind of
so some of the point is you have to
delete all the vertices that appear in
short cycles
yeah so okay one thing i realized we
didn't uh
really communicate is that um the reason
we need to
do this like whole deletion procedure is
because we were also actually
shooting for this additional robustness
property in our algorithm which is
um if an adversary deletes like delta
and
or or deletes or inserts delta n edges
where delta is a sufficiently small
constant we still wanted to solve the
distinguishing problem
sufficiently close to k s threshold uh
and that's why we needed to get the
proof to work for
like constant l otherwise the old
machinery does work without any like
um deleting vertices and short cycles or
deleting high degree vertices
and you just have to make l like log log
n squared
sorry but does this mean you don't get a
polynomial time algorithm
you do get a polynomial time algorithm
because i guess um these non-batch
driving powers
can be computed efficiently
uh also uh there's a comment from prasad
raghavendra in the audience
he says future direction number four
show lower bounds for the number of
rounds of local statistics stp hierarchy
below the ks threshold this will be
evidence towards
proving a computational phase transition
where the problem can be solved by
degree 2 local statistics above ks
threshold
and no constant degree local statistics
scp below the ks threshold
yeah i think maybe just might have
implicitly said that uh question in her
talk but
um yes this is also a great open
direction i think
yeah sort of text without i i meant to
add it but forgot about it
can i ask the question about this
robustness guarantee
so there were i think there was uh there
was there by
anker and alex and amelia
several years ago now which showed some
lower bounds about
also having to do with robustness and i
don't remember exactly what the
formulation of their result
was can you say what is the relationship
between these things and
and whether you're
yeah so actually in that paper what they
showed is that
um depending on the so so
yeah depending on what the adversary
depending on the number of insertions
and deletions that the adversary can
make
the ks threshold actually shifts up
um and they gave an algorithm that was
robust
at twice the ks threshold uh but i guess
ours is like a more
fine drained robustness theorem where um
we're able to say we can get b robust
to delta and edge insertion deletions
epsilon closest threshold where epsilon
depends on delta
uh and okay one one thing that i do want
to point out is in their paper
they actually considered a different
noise model as well whereas the
adversity is monotone the others he
could
add as many addresses they wanted
between communities and
subtract as many edges as possible
within communities or maybe the opposite
uh but okay we we only allow like
bounded numbers and i guess trying to
see if like these ideas can
be used to get better settings in the
other noise model is also a cool
direction
thanks i don't know if everybody saw but
in the chat
alex uh once a different form of
robustness we allowed an arbitrary
number of
monotone changes yeah that was actually
the model that i just
mentioned yeah
let's see some more questions
do you have like uh go ahead chris
so i think i'm just saying back what
students just said
i just want to understand so it could be
that
actually counting self-avoiding walks up
to a certain length could be somewhat
more powerful
than kind of that level of
of using non-backtracking walks but on
the other hand
doing that for lengths larger than log n
is computationally expensive for uh
self-avoiding walks whereas for
non-backtracking walks there's a linear
recurrence
that allows you to do it in polynomial
time so that's
kind of yeah that's sort of okay anyway
that's interesting
yeah i was gonna ask can you prove like
lower bounds for this local statistics
scp for like any kind of
like toy problem easier problem
right right um i guess for the if the
sos degrees too
we show that if you make your local
statistics degree any large enough
constant
you can't beat the k s threshold
um in the case of d regular graphs and
it's the
regulations
um but i guess
yeah i guess we we don't know any lower
bounds where
you're allowed to up the sof degree
right so i think analogous to sos where
there's kind of this quadratic barrier
where
lots of nice things happen yeah though i
think i should
i should mention the the the
barack hopkins uh kothari puritan
moitra kelner paper for like
uh some special one for planet please it
also gives a
local statistics lower bound
though this like pre-staged local
statistics so they don't like
say it that way hmm i see
i think in general pseudo calibration
based approaches
probably should give local statistics
lower bounds that's that's like
the the sense i have is the same true
for the sharington kirkpatrick
lower bounds um
yeah oh i guess oh it's true for
strictly being a true for the planet
boolean vector lower bound
for the sd lower bounds comes from like
another layer of reduction so
like you you have to you have to talk
about what planet model you're
using if you if you're asking about
local statistics actually
okay
actually at some point wouldn't you
expect local statistics
uh to to do something interesting in in
shannon kirkpatrick because of andrea's
algorithm
uh-huh so i guess we we also need to be
clear about which computation problem
we are talking about so if you talk
about refutation
it's not clear it should but maybe for
search
presumably yeah because undressing
applies only is talking about the random
problem where you don't have some
planted structure so that's
actually okay so it's you need to define
something yeah but
you can create something like a solution
that matches moments of the gibbs
distribution
then maybe at some number of levels
something interesting could happen
this is going back a little in time but
prasad uh also made a comment
addressing chris's question he said that
the number of short cycles of length
less than log n
is small and deleting our add them would
not change the the statistics in this
model so the sdp is not sensitive to it
um i i guess this is a much more naive
question but
sort of uh for for the community
detection type questions
i can understand that you know these are
the the sort of statistics that you look
at are related to sort of the local
structures and the graphs and you look
at non-backtracking walks and so on so
forth right
but sort of to one of the questions that
siddhanth had on slide leading to for
example spiked wigner matrices and stuff
you would look at sort of these same
length k
non-backtracking walks possibly on the
wigner matrix but in some sense they are
not so
local right so i guess i'm wondering
sort of in
other problems how local you expect
things to be and what that would mean
i guess if you have some understanding
of that
right so uh i guess one thing
to keep in mind is that the local
statistics sap is looking at
more than just the local structures in
the graph because it's also trying to
search for
like a planted spike at the same time
sure so presumably even in
something like spiked wegner
if i take two vertices and i look at all
length l non-backtracking walks between
these two vertices
let's say multiply the edge weights i
think i would expect that to be
correlated with
the product of oh yeah i don't know i'm
sure
i'm saying that maybe they are not so
local in this sense but
yeah sure
okay do we have more questions for
siddhant and jess
yeah how how does the running time
depend on your proximity to the ks
threshold
right it's actually a reasonably good
dependence because
um the sos degree only needs to be two
and
the only one that's increasing is the
number of constraints and the number of
machines just becomes like a
large constant and computing these
matrices takes like
um computing the m matrix takes order m
um matrix multiplication
equations so so it actually stays like
an sdb solve plus like matrix
multiplication solve
great okay so we have uh um
another talk in two minutes so we'll all
take a little teeny break and if uh
ahmed wants to set up
that'd be great i think he should be
able to control the screen share